hi everyone this is Jerry and this is a
game analysis between Gary Kasparov and
the musician sting this game was played
back in 2000 it was a simultaneous
exhibition that Kasparov held rating and
commenting this video are appreciated
and any questions you have for me feel
free to send on my way hope you enjoyed
the video
because Favre opens the game with the
move pawn to g3 making way for the
bishop to come to g2 sting opens up with
Knight to f6 a developing move Bishop to
g2 development pawn to e5 establishing
upon on one of these four central
squares and also allowing the bishop to
come out along this diagonal pawn to d3
this move is directed at securing the
Kings Knight development to the f3
square notice that if the knight were to
come here right away
black at play pawn to e4 the knight is
attacked and will now need to find a new
home so first pawn to d3 Bishop to c5
development in making way to Castle
Knight to f3 development attacking the
pawn and also getting ready to castle
pawn to d6 defense in making way for the
bishop to come out along this diagonal
castle developing move and black is
similar with castling pawn to c4 removed
erected that's securing this d5 square
white would like to prevent black from
advancing this pawn to d5 so that the
position does not become open and if the
position comes open the black rooks will
maybe have something to do constructive
in the position White's other idea is to
be preventing the black pawn from coming
to e4 Knight to c6 development Knight to
c3 development in this Knight is nicely
placed such that it's guarding both d5
and e4 Bishop to g4 development and
getting ready to form a battery if black
is allowed to he'd like to come to d7
and focus his sights on moving the g4
Bishop to h3 and once there could
exchange itself off for whites
King Bishop but cuz farmer stop sigh
right away and just puts a question to
the Bishop upon h3 Bishop takes Knight
in Bishop captures Bishop and what has
already accumulated at least one
advantage in this position why gave up a
knight and in return got a bishop
Bishop's are generally considered to be
better than Knights one reason for that
is because bishops are long range pieces
Queen to d7 attacking the h3 pawn bishop
to g2 defense pawn to a6 and move direct
adapt preserving this bishop in order to
me to move like Knight to a4 with Bishop
to a7 on the e3 taking away the d4
square from the bishop and Knight Bishop
to b4 attacking the knight Knight to e2
this move is a bit awkward it seems like
white is wasting time by retreating a
piece but that time loss will be gained
back with moves like pond ax a3 and pawn
to b4 where in both instances those
moves will be attacking this Bishop rook
on 88 white is trying to maybe get this
sort of advance in but he's not able to
do so successfully in fact no pawn move
that black makes in this game benefits
his position may be a better tries to
try and get a move like pond from f7 to
f5 where once that pawn is there then
maybe a move like Pondy 4 or f5 is more
of a possibility as it turns out black
is not able to do moves the do pawn
moves which are beneficial to him and as
a result because fire I was able to just
squeeze him rook on a to e8 on a3
attacking the bishop Bishop c5 Queen to
c2 I move directed at preventing both
pawn advances to d5 and e4e for is
guarded three times by the Queen pawn
bishop and if pawn to d5
pawn takes pawn and black doesn't have
time to recapture the pawn here because
the Queen is hitting the bishop so after
Queen to c2 we have rook to e7 black
unfortunately is doing something
equivalent to trying to walk through a
door that is not yet opened or in other
words this efile is closed because
there's a black and white pawn it's
considerably closed rooks function much
better on both semi open or open files
the e-file is closed these rooks really
don't contribute well to the position
pawn to b4 attacking the bishop bishop
to a7 retreat Knight to c3 repositioning
focusing again on these two squares rook
on F to e8 unless this file can open up
these rooks basically just look silly
bishop to d2 connecting the white rooks
and now a blunder pawn to d5 this move
this pawn advance needed the support of
one additional piece right now it's
attacked three times and it's only
defended twice that's just not enough
so miscalculation by black and now it's
just way downhill from here
after pawn takes pawn the knight is
attacked the knight has to retreat pawn
to e4 just securing that pawn Plus that
white has upon the h6
making way for the King to come to h7 in
the event of a white rook maybe getting
to the back rank at a later stage in the
game Bishop to e3 attacking the bishop
and now pawn to b6 and this looks a bit
awkward because this bishop really isn't
doing anything constructive now but if
the bishop word take that would result
in pawn takes Bishop and now this F file
is half open and so you might see moves
like rook to f3 followed by rook to rook
on a to f1
so although these puns are doubled what
you have as compensation is play along
the F file so instead of Bishop takes
Bishop sting plays pawn to b6 Knight to
e2 along the Queen to focus on c6 Knight
to b7 repositioning eyeing up the d6
square pawn to g4 making way for the
knight to pivot on g3 and from there
could go to f5 or even h5 rook to c8 9 2
G 396 and now Queen to c6 offering a
queen exchange often a very good
strategy if you're up material try and
trade down or trade the Queen's Queen
takes Queen pawn takes Queen and now R
up to d8 with thoughts of adding
pressure to d3 pawn to a4 stopping the
knight from coming to b5 night c8 the
rook is now attacking the pawn these are
just one move threats by black and
they're easily stopped by white or
cotton F 2 d1 defense
rook to e6 attacking the pawn pawn to b5
supporting the pawn upon the a5 and this
Bishop is officially a prisoner it can't
get out because of these ponds this
Bishop is essentially off the board
Bishop f3 repositioning black could
already resigned at this point in the
game it's just a matter of winning for
black not that sting was really going to
because far but rook on e to d6 adding
pressure to d3 Bishop e2 defense night
to h7 with dots are coming to g5
Kasparov takes that square away Knight
to e7 Knight to f5 once again just
getting ready to exchange more pieces
Knight takes Knight pawn on G takes
knight on f6 lending support to e5 rook
to a3 adding a defender to d3 King to h8
to d2 rook to g8 getting ready to come
to g6 to open up this file because prior
stops that as well and clamps down on
the g6 square
Knight to g5 getting ready to come to
maybe h3 that's not really a threat King
to f1 Knight to h3 Bishop to g4
attacking the knight Knight f4 and now
we see pawn to d4 often a good strategy
this pawn right now is a defender of the
night good strategy is to attack the
defending the defender of one's pieces
and now just a serious blunder pawn
takes pawn allows Bishop captures Knight
and it's just a matter of winning this
game very quickly and the bishop is now
attacking the rook the rook moves out of
the way white plays to e2 with the king
the bishop could take the pawn but why
do that this Bishop is already trapped
so why give him the opportunity to maybe
escape along this diagonal rook to e8
King to d3 defends the pond rookie 7
bishop d1 black doubles rooks pawn to f3
supporting e4 rook to d8 Bishop b3 and
black resigns and for good reason
there's no way to stop the following
moves by white this is how white would
would improve his position if black were
to play out and let me just move back
and forth with this bishop in the
meantime white could make these sorts of
moves where the rooks are just going to
double on the G file and these two
bishops will just break down along these
diagonals and white will essentially
crash through on g7 so that's all for
this video I hope you got something out
of it rating and commenting are
appreciated thanks so much bye-bye